on a dit il ya vingt ans à bhopal se
dérouler le plus terrible des accident
industriel de l'histoire une fuite de
gaz toxique
l usine américaine union carbide et a
provoqué la mort de plus de 20000
personnes et au total ce sont plusieurs
centaines de milliers d'habitants de la
ville qui ont été plus ou moins touchés
par cette catastrophe ce matin le match
des rescapés des familles des victimes
et de ceux qui militent pour que soit
indemnisé enfin comme il se doit ces
hommes et ces femmes une procession vers
le site abandonné de la société
américaine devant laquelle si j'en
prenais des effigies vingt ans après il
n'y a toujours pas eu de procès des
années de bataille juridique qui
n'aboutissent pas malgré l'obstination
des associations qui exige que les fonds
d'indemnisation d'indemnisation soit
distribué dans leur totalité
or seulement une partie est parvenue aux
victimes ce soir une avancée tout de
même dans le dossier
le gouvernement indien vient d'annoncer
qu'il allait enfin débloquer la totalité
des fonds sur place christian hottin
yann moix blessés dans leur chair les
veuves de bhopal lutte contre l'oubli
toutes ont perdu un mari ou un enfant
dans la catastrophe
chaque samedi elle se retrouve dans ce
parc du centre ville pour réclamer des
réparations
laissé pour compte elles font partie des
25 mille victimes qui n'ont jamais
touché l'indemnité au moins jusqu'à
aujourd'hui je n'ai pas eu d'argent à
une roupie ni avant ni maintenant on a
bien fait des démarches pour remplir le
dossier
mais comment voulez vous que j'y arrive
je ne sais ni lire ni écrire
en 1989 d'union carbide propriétaire de
l'usiné meurtrière a bien versé 470
millions de dollars dix fois moins que
ce que réclamait le gouvernement indien
chaque victime aperçue l'équivalent de
400 euros en plusieurs versements
une somme jugée dérisoire pour réparer
les dégâts irréversibles causés par le
gaz
elle est dure mais là ils appellent ça
des compensations vous voulez rire
cet argent a tout juste suffi à payer
les médicaments et les soins dont j'ai
besoin pour survivre
l'argent des indemnités a aussi servi a
construit en 2001 cet hôpital
ultramoderne un lieu dédié en principe
aux victimes du gaz grâce à cette carte
ils peuvent bénéficier de soins gratuits
et d'une technologie de pointe
problème pour continuer à fonctionner
l'hôpital a aussi besoin de patients qui
payent leurs soins cet hôpital ne donne
pas la priorité aux victimes du gaz de
lourdes interventions chirurgicales
peuvent y être pratiqués ce dont ils
n'ont pas besoin ses victimes mais c'est
nécessaire pour attirer les patients qui
ont beaucoup d'argent et big man i et
victimes ont enfin obtenu le paiement
d'une nouvelle indemnité de 400 euros
par personne
il somme pourtant bien là suffisante
pour apaiser la douleur des survivants
en colère